hallo leute wir sind heute in kunst und
wir dachten wir nutzen die gelegenheit
mal und gehen für euch wieder auf die
straße unser thema ist heute was mögen
deutsche an anderen ländern und kulturen
deutsche reisen ja gerne unter wollen
hören was mögen sie an anderen kulturen
und rücklings was sagt uns das über die
deutsche kultur
wir fangen jetzt in köln und vielleicht
auch noch in einem von anderen städten
los geht's die frage ist was magst du an
anderen ländern bereit zu gerne die alle
gerne und hätte gerne hin
ich würde am liebsten einfach alles mal
sehen wird dann deutschland irgendwie
scheinen die warmen temperaturen in
anderen mehr dass die hauptmotivation
warmes meer vielleicht auch das nur wenn
wir hier ostsee nordsee bei
schwierigkeiten lieblingsland wo die
erste show ich war noch nicht selten
öfter in die gleichen gegen aber kanadas
deshalb mein favorit ich heute wird habe
ja noch vor allem und was magst du an
italien
die kultur die tische leute die sprache
ich mag mittelamerikanischen länder ganz
gern aber ich habe costa rica zum
beispiel ganz besonders und genau da
habe ich ein jahr gelebt und deshalb
was am meisten an dass in italien
eintreffen
das lebensgefühl die lebenseinstellung
der menschen dort
jänner und juni 2010 also herrn
superstar sind und ich fahren kambodscha
eigentlich schon vietnam auf und wo
welche länder mainz luftig mag irland
sehr gerne weil ich da ein jahr gewohnt
habe als aupair mädchen und ich mag die
wanzen zusammen in fragen der tscheche
macht sehr und holen mag ich auch sehr
gerne da bin ich auch gutes für gutes
essen und gibt seinen körper rica wo
sich die deutschen eine scheibe von
abschneiden können mit spontaneität beim
tanzen also da trifft man sich einfach
freitagabend und macht die zeit der
musik an und damit laut getarnt und die
deutschland haben wir noch unser zu
schüchtern dann würde ich mal sagen da
könnten sich schon auf jeden fall eine
scheibe von abschneiden von der
lebensfreude einfach und wenn du dir die
länder wurde schon was anguckt und die
mit deutschland vergleicht was würdest
du gern von dort aus importieren
lebensjahr ich finde es schön dass in
vielen anderen ländern muss sagen punkte
von offenheit und die leute miteinander
irgendwie freundlicher umgehen und
wieder herzlich als doch manchmal in
deutschland der fall
in deutschland sind die leute nicht so
herzlich wenig immer in köln schon
[Gelächter]
irgendwas mitnehmen könnte es auch
australien
was du willst in deutschland wird sie
auch gäbe was wäre wahrscheinlich die
lockerheit also wenn wir da ich habe
leute zweimal getroffen haben die mir
mein geld zusammen einen kaffee oder so
was halt alles zahlt zunächst mal
bezahlt hat der andere war als richtig
locker 160 mehr buch geführt hat oder so
was er macht geteilt hat den deutschen
jeder in deutschland würden sich im
zweifel die jeder erstmal virgins
blockieren wie viele jetzt vater der für
den anderen bezahlt hat und das war halt
der chemie ja die heutige frage habe ich
auch mal wieder bei facebook gestellt
und da haben wir ganz interessante
antworten bekommen zum beispiel julia
geschrieben
wien genesis british people wounded
kannst du beim ground das ist auch ganz
typisch in deutschland kauft immer jeder
versicherte zahlt auch für sich und man
gibt nicht so gerne einen aus oder er
wird beschrieben ein ding das sich an
der amerikanischen kultur überhaupt
nicht mag ist die tatsache dass wir
immer noch zur arbeit gehen auch wenn
wir krank sind
die idee dass man zu hause bleiben soll
um sich zu erholen und sonst niemanden
anzustecken würde ich sehr gerne von der
deutschen kultur übernehmen
lieblingsland brand weil mein vater
kommt daher des angreifers und was
gefällt dir in griechenland was man
solche in deutschland nicht finden würde
ja generell darf mehr der strand als
alles viel lockerer als der strecke gibt
zwar gar nicht ihm viel glück in allen
tut hier im café und filme kann hier
manchmal bei man hat hier schon immer
den druck
warum machen sich deutsche gestressten
der zufällig gerade dieses wohnung
vorbei kommen sie meine schwester die
mondjahren köln
wir klingen einfach mal anschauen auch
sie da ist hallo sage ich für mich
völlig überflüssig ins mikrofon rom
geschwister hilfe direkt rein ganze
wohnung
ich mag auch immer auch gerne in
supermärkte zu gehen
da kriegt man zu den haag mit die
streitereien an der theke und ansonsten
wie für deutschland
das kennenlernen der natur zu gehen von
anderen kulturen was du gerne nach
deutschland bringen würde es mal
freundlich gastfreundlichkeit sonst
bereit ihre lebensfreude kolumbien
bildungsökonomin als die leute wie
fandest du kolumbien schwankungen sehr
sehr bunt sehr herzlich sehr divers
abwechslungsreiche natur märz gibt's
dann wirklich wirklich alles wäre freund
nicht mehr lustig wäre
sie lachen viel tanzen für musik
ursprung kann als im irak dort hätten
wir die gastfreundschaft und die warme
herzlichkeit wer die mir doch schon früh
zu sagen wie der typische deutsche
direkt aber eine bitte immer korrekt
doch nett und klar muss ihn erst zwei
jahre lang kennenlernen freut sich
öffnet das eis brechen
die nuss knacken genug war yasuo
yamamoto aus japan schreibt
ich hätte gerne den mut der deutschen
nein zu sagen also die japaner sind
immer sehr höflich und manchmal würde er
sich wünschen dass die japaner ein
bisschen direkter werden so wie die
deutschen
da ja hat geschrieben the jewish way of
grief auch sehr spannend das wusste ich
gar nicht
da hat sie beschrieben wie die juden
trauern dass sie eine bestimmte zeit
sich nehmen um eine person zu trauern
die gestorben ist während in vielen
anderen kulturen das thema eher
verschwiegen wird und man nicht weiß wie
man darüber reden kann ist und schreibt
die detailfreudig kite der deutschen
matthias schreibt die pünktlichkeit der
deutschen kultur
michael fried chinesisches essen und mit
stäbchen essen und politik schreibt
zuvor breakfast von vietnam
also es gibt eine ganze reihe dinge die
sich leute aus anderen funktionen gerne
wünschen würden
ein bisschen mehr lockerheit auf jeden
fall ein bisschen was aus lateinamerika
würde ich cool finden die sich offen
miteinander umgehen gehen die menschen
in lateinamerika miteinander um
einfach alle dinge sind offen und
freundlich also einfach total offen
befindet und in deutschland wir sind
später griesgrämiger kommt drauf an
welche ecke
von von der mode die leute den alle
schüler giganten die aufgeschlossene art
teilweise also in deutschland befindet
auch hier in berlin
aber natürlich auch die abgeschottete
und jederzeit für sich individuell und
wie und macht sein eigenes ding und in
anderen ländern hat man doch eher noch
dieses gesellschaftliche etwas stärker
wo heute wirklich mehr leben einfach
herrscht und würde ich auch genau zu
sagen also die offenheit wenn sie kein
englisch können versuchen sie trotzdem
noch irgend jemanden dazuzuholen der
helfen kann oder angemessen beziehen
ja das ist der punkt hier in deutschland
hat man oft wurden peter bestellt sich
im restaurant seinen eigenen teller und
ist von seinem eigenen teller woanders
kommen 811 ein kleiner teller und eine
große sache das essen drauf ist und man
isst gemeinsam vom leben ein teller so
viele kleine schäden genau und das mag
ja auch ganz gerne
ja liebe leute jetzt möchten von euch
wissen was möchtet ihr gerne von anderen
ländern und kulturen lernen oder in
feuerland importieren das wollen wir
unbedingt wissen schreibt es uns in die
kommentare und wenn ihr lust habt noch
übungen zu machen vokabeln zu lernen zu
dem thema heute werdet schon bei uns so
könnt ihr unser projekt unterstützen und
als am leben halten
und natürlich müssen wir unseren kanal
abonnieren abonniert hier danke für zu
schauen um das nächste woche drauf